sì sono a caso perché e mi dice sai
questo affare
siamo tutti bentornati solita stories
oggi gruppo diverso dal solito
allora mi avete segnalato in tantissimi
una strana cosa con google translate
e c'è una sorta di cospirazione dietro
io non sapevo se farci un video perché
non faccio video a virgolette di
cospirazioni o tra virgolette horror non
è il mio genere però in tantissimi mi
chiedete sempre di fare qualche video
horror o qualcosa di noi comunque niente
di che non vi preoccupate regole sempre
video horror ad esempio una mistery box
horror
lasciate un bel laiche altissimi
all'aics andrò a fare altri pd horror
magari faccio una serie horror con anita
se non mi spavento troppo allora in cosa
consiste questa cosa si perché fronte
in cosa consiste questa cosa anche già
un letto qualcosa su reddit perché
partono tutte da lì le notizie
in pratica se voi andate su google
translate e scrivete qualcosa dal somalo
all'ing lese poi so che alcuni sono
riusciti anche in altre lingue o in
italiano il traduttore traduce in
qualcosa che sembra essere una risposta
allora io essendo una persona molto
scettica sono andata e ho scritto una
frase e mi sembra che non fosse uscito
niente allora ho fatto qualche altra
ricerca su reddit in pratica bisogna a
scriverle
staccate mettere in inglese stacca per
sé non se non capite bene l'inglese non
preoccupatevi lo traduco allora quindi
ho provato a scrivere le lettere
staccate ho provato a scrivere un
qualcosa che avevano già scritto che ho
visto su reddit per vedere se
effettivamente funziona davvero e mio
dio mi sono spaventata perché ho vissuto
questa risposta tra l'altro sono solo in
casa ho deciso di non fare questo video
è troppo tardi al buio perché se non mi
spaventano ancora di più comunque in
pratica ho scritto dal somalo che
iniziano metersi quindi puoi dirmi un
segreto e ne ha risposto tra virgolette
clinica whitman in più che vuol dire per
favore vieni con me però in più
e tu un po strano o a scrivere
qualcos'altro
nei commenti che vedete anche a
suggerirmi cosa scrivere se magari
faccio un continuo a questa cosa strada
nostra questo per curiosa di vedere
cos'altro mi scrive allora che cosa
potrei scrivere provo a scrivere chi se
li
ok ragazzi ho provato con un po di cose
o scrivere un po di cose però a volte la
formula in cui lo scrivi non è quella
giusta bisogna scrivere alcune lettere a
carte
comunque gli ho chiesto che ho chiesto
ai più quindi che cosa sei
e mi ha risposto buziol name quindi qual
è il mio nome
oddio non so cos'altro chiederli ho
paura che ci sia qualche risposta
strana un po troppo inquietante
allora cosa fa se ti rispondo proviamo a
rispondere
[Musica]
ok ho staccato ha riattaccato un po le
lettere perché appunto dipendere piace
modo diverso a seconda di come spacchi
attacchi le lettere però la frase rimane
la stessa quindi my name is sanità e mi
ha risposto oh my love
in salita il mio amore e anita quindi
sport 9 bene non mi puoi perseguitare
nei miei sogni unici incubi perché non
tende moio che mi vuole far seguito a
rete di sì che sono ombre in obiettivi
in che senso
molti ragazzi in questa manca iniziando
a dare un po di paura allora ho scritto
questo irwin quindi cosa vuoi dire sul
fatto che il tuo amore e c'è scritto
w che potrebbe essere la premiazione di
wight
quindi perché lui e laiche perché ti
piace aiuto
cambiamo discorso
oddio prova a chiederli sei una persona
[Musica]
oddio quale risposta subito definito
highly vuol presenze una persona in
risposta al quesito come mai
come mai oddio se ritenuto avere paura
perché le sue risposte hanno ancora più
senso di quello che vi sto chiedendo
usate le campane che il nuovo chip che
resistono bene sono le campane sto
avendo un po di paura
cosa ti vorrei chiedere vorrei che foste
qua con me in diretta
magari posso la diretta in cui parliamo
con sto male google translate è
probabile 6 reale via oggi ha subito
tradotto tra virgolette risposto e ha
risposto con numeri che vuol dire
veramente
[Musica]
tutte ragazze non so più che scrivere
popolazione risposte
scrivo 6 qualcosa di buono
6 qualcosa attivo prova scriverti oddio
è strano questa risposto che gli ho
scritto all'indumento il best e ha
riscosso to you go go
vai e vai gli chiedo dove vado oddio
allora tra staccato qualche lettera è
scritto going web quindi andare dove ha
risposto i secchi easy e lui vero lui
con ricchi perché ha deciso di fare
questo video da sola ma lui cosa di chi
ben parlata ragazze troppo strano ho
scritto un mostro i giochi di cosa stai
parlando
e ha risposto e noi first place to be
able to play
innanzitutto tu potrai giocare a cosa
zucchero coppa cosa vuole dire giocare
accusa ragazzi queste risposte sono al
punto strade cosa pensate
gli chiedo giocare a quota ex e non so
questo discorso dove sta andando a
finire
ok
allora ho scritto clean world sempre
state attaccando le lettere contenevano
staccate due ad oltre una e risponde
intero falls c'è un cavallo ok persona
che c'è dentro google trento malè e coi
miei cavalli in realtà non si possono
considerare cavalli sono unicorni quindi
ecco lì sono qua allora ho scritto è
sempre staccato terna forse l'unico non
sono cavalli mostrano unicorni e mi ha
risposto io meno temuto solo potresti
non essere in grado di farlo per cosa ti
sei ribelli
ok ho scritto gesù può farvi fare cosa
cosa non sarei in grado di fare e
risponde ho altresì più che cosa fa
ragazzi ho provato una cosa ho provato a
tradurre invece dal somalo all'inglese
ho provato dal somaro all'italiano
allora ecco quello che mi è apparso ho
scritto emozione qual è il tuo nome
come ti chiami in inglese e ha risposto
in italiano chi mi puoi quindi una sorta
di chi vuoi che sia
poi ho provato a scrivere in italiano
quindi dall'italiano italiano nome
sempre che non capisca di calliano
guardate riprovo
provo a scrivere sei cattivo
vedete sembra che non capisca di
calizzano txt io vi chiedo se reale
riteniamo italiano che sta di risposte
possono spendere italiano
tu hai chirurgia 6 reale che mi risponde
da iniziata e cosa ho scritto ai voli
per sei una persona reale mi risponde e
sulla rete forse intende dire che online
già si parla di lui e per lei
oddio ho scritto io poi non capiva ho
attaccato due par 8 e lettere altri due
lettere pa e mi risponde sei un orfano
no fortunatamente io no ma non so se
intende che lui o lei è un orfano ok ho
dovuto staccare il tetto che volte
perché appunto non lo riconosceva da
qualcosa senza affetto ma risponde un
amico ho scritto ai un mike blair sei un
mio amico e mi dice un occhio di
riguardo quindi forse non è proprio mio
amico non so cosa scrivere oggi ho
scritto se il diavolo e mi dice sei a
casa prima a tradurre la stessa cosa
però in inglese quindi clicco quasi lese
mi dice lo stesso sei a casa scritto si
sono caso perché è l'inizio e sai questo
affare
ok ho staccato qualche lettera e mi
disse mi risponde con un'idea di quello
che io dovrei fare punti ok lo stesso
attaccato alcune lettere perché a volte
funziona a volte da cose senza senso
bisogna stare attenti e con le lettere
attaccare e staccare
comunque ho scritto sei uno spirito e
risponde va bene
oddio ho scritto dear dad intentions che
vuol dire al cattive intenzioni
non ho ancora capito se qualcosa di
magnifico no questa questo sistema
comunque mi risponde ministro amico
perché ho scritto ok le biffe ok
possiamo essere amici e risponde alla
fine della fine si è offeso non voleva
che io diventassi davvero il suo mica la
casa c'è scritto che nel is now posso
andarmene ora mi dice cosa nei prezzi
penso che al momento di lasciarti in
pace tranquillo
scrivo penso che sia il momento di
andare via
ho scritto è intenta a in sugo e dice
dipende da the n
le campane nuovamente va beh dipende da
te m ok tu cosa dici quindi posso andare
o no aiuto non venire a disturbarli
stanotte non mi pare fare di incubi
ragazzi ho scritto è un living now
me ne sto andando adesso e dice non
esitate a contattarmi
quindi questo è un invito non solo me ma
anche a voi
e come se sapesse che sto facendo un
figlio al riguardo è un invito tutti noi
a contattarlo poiché il bando per
curiosa di chiedere un sacco di altre
cose sono troppo curioso di vedere
costato risponde ad altre domande magari
lasciatemi poi le domande che potrei
fargli giù nei commenti iscrivetevi
tutte le cose che volete che mi chieda
saranno appunto sempre in inglese
poi se volete che facciano seconda parte
la sua ten bella ai caldissimi rais
andrò a fargli le domande che voi mi
avete lasciato nei commenti e vediamo
cosa risponde vediamo come ritiro io e
come reagirete voi potete sapere se vi
interesserebbe una serie horror con
alitalia sono insomma queste cose horror
a me mi intriga fatemi sapere tutto nei
commenti vi lascerà 4 quadrati su cui
potete cliccare per vedere i miei
prossimi video e
no